see you guys back here on monday at 2  p.m eastern on youtube and facebook but  before we go it's friday and if you're  planning on doing any drinking this  weekend do not take any tips from jimmy  fallon on how to drink beer i love this  so much this is so funny jimmy was the  center of attention at the new york  rangers game last night where he was  seen frantically shoving down a hot dog  before attempting to chug his beer  take a look we'll see you back here next  time bye kisha  bye  chuckle and jimmy fallon was on the big  screen showing some of the celebrities  in the stands  once he recognized that he was on the  camera  puts on a show as usual  host of the tonight show